I can't give you an answer I don't know
and I don't care that much if I had to
say it there's two holes top hole bottom
hole straw has one hole just because
it's a really long hole doesn't mean
there's two holes obviously this has one
hole
see there's one here and it goes all the
way through and on the other side it's
the same hole do you see two holes here
I don't I see one it's zero holes
because it is a tube I think it's either
zero holes or two holes right because I
feel like a tube has to have two holes
right because it's this you're right I
don't know I knew but I don't
my gut was one maybe it's two but then
we're talking about what the definition
of a hole is and then what the
definition of a straw is one two it's a
tube but it has tools okay this has zero
holes and here's my argument for why
it's a tube there is a single opening
that goes all the way through but this
straw has no holes right now
but then it's like is it really a hole
because a hole is something you dig in
the ground right you dig down and you
build a hole and if there's something
solid and I've just said the word holes
wait too much it checks you because
there's two ends so you think that
there's two holes but it's like one hole
with an in and out point I'm going one
hole
some people might think that this is two
holes I understand that argument but if
you're thinking about like physics why's
the way this tool also is meant to be
used is there what suction through one
hole oh but then the liquid has to come
in one hole and out the other into your
mouth so potentially it's two holes
I was really aggressively on the single
hole train the entire time and now that
I'm talking about it I can't actually
defend one hole because if there was
only one hole in a straw you wouldn't be
able to suck anything through it then it
would just be a vase
you